have you ever had a teacher that was
just
well kind of boring
maybe even a little robotic
we've all been there let's face it it's
hard to learn
when you're being put to sleep
but what if we found a completely new
way of learning
could a robot be a better teacher than a
human
how might education change with ai
and what are the pros and cons
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if your teacher was an ai
[Music]
schools all over the world are
experimenting with new ways of teaching
using technology as our population
reaches critical mass
we may not have enough teachers for
every child on the planet
could robot teachers be a solution
or could that turn into a scary crisis
for
our species whether you're for it or
against it scientists believe artificial
intelligence in the classroom
is not far off
that is of course if classrooms still
exist
so what would happen if we replaced all
our teachers with
a.i they may
look like us or they could be entirely
virtual
like an avatar on a screen regardless of
what they look or sound like ai and
education will simplify
administrative tasks that eat up a lot
of time
grading exams will be automated learning
interfaces will become smarter with
interactive textbooks
and people with learning disabilities or
different learning styles will be
better accommodated everything will be
standardized and
customized to help students learn more
effectively
students could even choose to focus on
more specialized
subjects based on their interests
which could help them discover their
passions or quirky
nerdy obsessions earlier in life
[Music]
according to a 2016 unesco report
an additional 20.1 million teachers
are needed to meet the goals for equal
access to education
by 2030
many schools are already looking into
advanced systems to help
close this gap for instance automated
services like
backpacks use algorithms to read
children's handwriting
and to grade tests and assignments
[Music]
in china ai is used to create
personalized tutoring lessons
surveillance and even brainwave trackers
to
keep an eye on classroom progress
futurists believe education is moving
towards
highly individualized curricula allowing
students to learn at their own
pace without having to hold back others
with the proliferation of the internet
on a global scale
the limitations of education are
becoming a thing of the past
teachers are experimenting with virtual
classrooms
especially with the covet 19 pandemic
alongside this personalized data
availability
university and college admissions might
become automated as well
even job recruiters could potentially
use this data which
may tailor candidates to available
positions
also greater access to education
worldwide would mean
much higher competition for jobs and
with a more educated population
technological developments will
rapidly advance but
this new way of learning could come at a
price
so what exactly are the risks
if all our teachers were replaced by ai
we would have to be
extra careful about security
just as the media is plagued with fake
news
we would be at risk of having our
education systems hacked
to spread false information or
propaganda
[Music]
whoever rules ai holds the power to
manipulate
the entire world
[Music]
this new way of learning might also
affect children's health
with too much screen time being a known
cause of
obesity sleep disorders and a lack of
interpersonal development
so maybe try not to binge watch too many
what-if videos
we would also need widespread internet
wi-fi networks and electricity to power
all these devices
which could come at a great cost to our
planet
and if artificial intelligence becomes
so advanced
that it gains self-awareness or
sentience
our species might run into some problems
currently our ai is in the category of
artificial narrow intelligence
[Music]
it can perform tasks using human-like
capabilities
but it can only do what it's programmed
to do
with limited memory systems it can learn
and
improve on basic tasks but we're far off
from
a truly independent artificial
consciousness
[Music]
let's just be extra careful though and
try not to kick them around too much
i prefer to stay on their good side
we still can't authentically program
empathy
which is an important component human
teachers have
for many kids teachers act as guidance
counselors
role models coaches and even surrogate
parents
and we need teachers now more than ever
as of 2016 unesco has reported that
263 million children and youth
are out of school and more than 70
of them live in impoverished areas of
southern asia and sub-saharan africa
many teachers in these areas are with
little to no access to
educational resources having consistent
easily accessible ai enhanced education
online
could change these numbers drastically
perhaps our next phase of human
evolution is dependent
on a global ai school system
but if all our teachers can be replaced
with
artificial intelligence could other jobs
suffer the same fate
if you want to dive deeper into how we
humans might
one day co-exist with ai check out
our what if discussed episode where we
sit down
with professor joanna bryson a
specialist in artificial intelligence
who shares her thoughts
on our future with ai